part two of running security in my  brother's party and making people do  random things in order to get inside so  the next one i didn't get on video but i  literally wish i did because it was so  funny so this guy walks up to me and i  do my normal bit i take his temperature  with a remote and then i also tell him  that in order to get inside he's gonna  have to do push-ups and this guy looks  at me and he says i can't i don't have a  leg and i'm like yeah right okay  he pulls up his pant leg and he  literally has a prosthetic and then he's  like yeah i bet you feel bad now and i  look him dead in the eye and i say  so you're gonna let that hold you back  okay i know i'm a terrible person it was  a joke it was a joke i let him inside  but i was like what are the odds of that  out of all the people that i asked to do  random things throughout the day the one  guy asked to do push-ups does not have a  lag